this man uh he texted me good morning
and when he does that it means he wants
to talk come on
um and so uh he wants to talk and i like
talking to him
sue me he's number 99 in the program
number one in our hearts he's pro
football hall of famer and one of the
greatest bucks of all time warren sapp
how are you
good morning sir
okay so what you got the best stories
you know what man i've i've been lucky
i've been lucky you know how did you
find out you were in the hall did you
who called you when you got in the got
that call from no you you remember i was
the year right before we turned it into
the big knock on the door and all of
that okay yeah right so and weinberger
and weinberger was begging me to take a
camera with me because we were down in
new orleans remember okay and so what
happened and i
and i told weinberg i said you're crazy
i say because if they don't call my name
right somebody's dying in that room and
i don't want to be the cameraman or you
know somebody had his own footage right
right
right
so i turned down the camera and me and
my boys we walked down and went to two
sisters because i had cut a deal with
the dude during the week that he said
he's gonna get me some crawfish so we
went down and got a hand grenade came
back the two sisters ate crawfish then
came went back to my hotel room
and who called you was it joe horgan
watching it on nfl network watching rod
woodson and the whole little panel y'all
had up there and they were talking and
and then um
in a hall of fame the brother uh did the
announcement oh
okay yeah his name escapes me right now
okay yeah excuse me too okay i can see
his face and his little no no i know i
remember him too yeah his little little
teeny weeny afro you know
right now
you know i remember yes yes yes yes yes
so uh okay and that's how you found out
you were in the hall and who was that
who was in your class again because
that's the thing about it too i love it
because i do remember that that class
with madden and and troy aikman and
harry carson and the three of us because
uh me and uh
the raiders went to the hall if we was
at the hall of fame game right
yeah i was with the raiders and we went
to all the same game when man got here
yeah that's right oh that's right okay
so you were there for that one who went
in the hall with you who went in the
hall with you who's in your class larry
allen chris carter
jonathan ogden
bill parcells
uh what was parcells like that week you
must have been hanging out with bill
that was oh my friend
the best
all right witch we walk in monday
and dave robertson
and chris carter uh that's the it's
seven of us so uh we walk in monday
and
bill parcells the big tuna stands up in
this room and says
first of all my name is dwayne
william parcell i almost fell over
i almost fell over in my chair
so now it's friday night and he's about
to walk across the stage and get his
jacket
i
wish i leaned over because it's just him
dave robertson and me left so i
so i leaned over it whispered in his ear
i said can i call you dewey
what'd he say
and i remember i remember chris carter's
speech chris carter's speech was great
like telling everyone to stand up and
then just go sit down mama oh you're in
the hall of fame he closed the show i
remember that that was a great speech no
he closed the show he's right
i remember that um and and i also well i
remember this too like a couple years
later for at ed reed's
uh party you guys were there brockman
and tj yeah and we saw jonathan ogden
yeah he is the largest human being i've
ever seen ever
anywhere
oh my god did you ever have to go
against him no you were there
he makes orlando page look like a
average sized guy that's true
that's true you didn't have to you'd
have to go against j.o right because he
was outside were you ever of course i
did of course
look dirtbag uh held me nice and good
one time with god bless his soul and
mcnair and mcnair was at quarterback and
man burgess was coming at him good that
day and he he yanked my jersey and i
looked back at him i said nice one he
was like oh that move i said don't worry
about it i got you you got me you got me
here's that nasty hole but then i got
him later on in the game he
we was going through our interview
process and he was like i don't think i
ever got beat by anybody i said excuse
me johnson and then i showed him a
picture of it
remember that one he was like oh yeah he
did get me that time all right yeah and
last one for you sap on on this whole uh
line of line of talk um was was deacon
jones alive or he had already passed
when you got in no a lot he was so so
then you walk in again for the hall for
folks you may not know the hall of fame
no no no no 2013 he was not alive no
okay but you knew him obviously because
he ran
he would be he would he would he would
hold what was called the nichky luncheon
which is a which is where the pro
football hall of fame incoming class
they were once they became rookies again
because you're a rookie for the for the
hall
and
rookie too right and and the whole room
would
tell you the responsibilities of being a
hall of famer and welcome you but also
kind of haze you a little bit and then
deacon took that over so who was doing
that was it willie lanier who was doing
it
yeah
right
who's going to take it over who who who
should take that one over
what do you think it will not it will
not it will not be one man because
because michael irving is going to do
his thing of course and then we got and
we got the preacher ray lewis we got to
give him a time limit because you know
he gonna you know he gonna put his down
and then whenever you got running a lot
of one of them old school dudes in there
right come on mel blunt and all of them
come on
it ain't gonna be one joe green's still
there
warren sapp here on the rich eisen show
okay
how's everybody you're like a kid i'm
like a kid in a candy store when i'm in
that room it's amazing you know i i i am
too when i go there it's just it's so
fun it's so fun and just to see you know
and girl and the hall of fame in canton
ohio is a great place to visit too if
you're ever in the area so let's let's
get right to it warren how are things in
tampa how's everything in tampa yeah
everything's gonna be all right
everything gonna be all right you know
what i'm saying because you know blue
knows that the goat does reside in tampa
correct mm-hmm
you know tom brady i mean i'm watching
your jets there on four foot two i say i
look at my legs baby if they
don't kick this ball and get up seven
probably absolutely gonna make them pay
and hey man
the man is just absolute he's surgical
with it
he doesn't miss
what did you think though uh when abe
left in the manner in which he did my my
mouth hit the floor
i hit somebody with the team
and i got the greatest response i could
ever get back i guess we got an extra
seat on the way home
that was it huh
hey
that i guess we got an extra seat on the
way home that that's that that's the
word i got so i said here we go let's go
play football because we down 14 in the
third quarter two three minutes left
i mean
he looked pretty healthy running off
that day
you know i i that's what i was saying
earlier before warren is that you know
brady
from all his years at new england where
they could put those like velvet ropes
around the clubhouse you know around the
club there
and
remove what normally would tear any
other locker room apart or what would
just consume the team in one media cycle
after another and take them out
where it would affect a win or a loss he
he he and the patriots back in the day
would build kings of that so i'm not
concerned about that and same with same
with aryans but i i am concerned about
the fact that brown isn't there when
godwin's not now are you
or what not right now not right now
because the
san francisco will be uh the rams this
weekend
we'll we'll finish off the carolina
panthers with the young fellas and
everything we got going because i mean
let's get in this tournament let's go
play
so when you're in a tournament though
what do you think about that
listen
when you talk about the speed of pyramid
and you saw what the young fella did
sunday you just got to be in the right
spot brady's going to put the ball there
and with the gloves they got on i mean
they shouldn't be dropping the ball
come on let's let's play this thing you
ain't got to worry about getting hit
anymore rich
come on
i told you they put an autobahn in the
middle of the football field and put
exits in off ramps everywhere
it's not precious with the yardage
anymore
that's why they do all kind of crazy
analytics and things because
the game is so wide open
you're all right so then let's let's
walk through this then um
that audubon's open for the the 12 in
green right and he's playing out of his
skull and 17 in green and 12 in green
are one of the greatest quarterback
receiver combinations in real time that
we've seen
right that's it just one man
well i mean you got 33. you know i got
aj dylan
i like to think when we get to the
playoffs
they're not gonna let matthew stanford
drop back and throw the ball to koopa
cup all day long they're not gonna allow
you know the uh your boy uh burroughs to
drop back and throw at the jamar chase
for 266 yards
somebody has got to come up with a
scheme that says you're gonna have to
throw it to your number two number three
guy
i i i have to i have to believe that
this is gonna happen in somebody's
defensive meeting room when the playoffs
get going because this ain't making no
sense to me well that's gonna happen in
tampa too right i mean wouldn't you make
sure that evans is gonna be blanketed so
then what all right all right now i got
mike i got a break i got uh 18 i got 15.
i got johnson now now now tell me which
one what now these are household names
so which one you don't double so you're
gonna double mike right yeah sure so now
that's outside that's why i want you
outside the numbers right because that
ain't what brady operates and now i
ain't even mentioned the grunkster i
ain't even got nasty with you and got
drunk in here
the middle of the field is wide open
rich
tom brady is going to get bucks 30
points i guarantee you this you're going
to need 30 to be there
what about the defense the house
now now you can put me in the hospital
and i see you see what's happening you
put me on the respirator now so you know
gave me covert or oriental and uh delta
and everything now see i got a lot of
problems with this
i was watching my defense on sunday and
i'm like we ain't getting no pressure on
the
quarterback yeah
what are you kidding me right now i'll
tell you what that kid's tough to put
down though that that kid
did you see joe burrow with him running
three
blitzers at him he avoids them and then
throws for seven yards on one gang four
yards running carrying somebody on
another one i'm like
boy is this kid doing this on a on a
reconstructed me and a bomb online oh my
god he's good and he yeah he's good
oh my goodness yeah they've suddenly
they've suddenly uh turned it on and you
know and now the derek henry the
diminisher as i like to call him he's
coming back
right you know and belichick's back in
the tournament the bills did make it
looks like they're going to play a home
game over in the
nfc though you've got the packers who
are playing out of their skulls kyler
murray is going to be in it too uh what
do you make of the cowboys what do you
make of them warren i don't know that
and that's always been a dilemma when i
saw that uh prescott with the
championship hat on i'm like there ain't
one nothing
i understand the division of the
division but
i i i think
that's the worst thing you can do for
the dallas cowboys
it's a crown of something how good is 11
how good is he
oh right
can we can we i love having a swiss army
knife on the football field right but i
love to have me somebody that's a master
at one thing
because if you if this kid can rush like
that and you rush him
80 of the time
what would his numbers be
off the charts
off the chart there's nobody yet man
[Music]
okay and we might as well go full circle
warren since this you know this is our
latest conversation in one of our first
involved straight hand sack record uh do
you think if uh oh my god
yeah what do you think what do you think
do you think tj if tj watts sends it
down um
and he gets an 18th week to do it even
though he hasn't even played 16 weeks
himself
no
matter what do you think it doesn't
matter okay so this doesn't matter like
it ain't like we changed it from
baseball like 154 games to 162. that's a
whole nother week you know i'm saying
it'll work well this is another week you
know what i mean like you're technically
not eight though
well i guess one game would be eight the
equivalent of eight in baseball in a way
that's the way you know
that's how he does how do you look at it
yeah i mean if you want to but well i
mean put an asterisk on both of them you
know how i feel about that
[Laughter]
you might not be fishing but i was right
there and i finally got a bite just like
i did 18 years ago you already know
there's no way there's no way you're
gonna talk to me with that with that
with the downtime about putting the acid
going on the white kid and not an astro
on the slide that's trey you put an
asterisk on straight on the slide the
slide
you do not get a sat down 16 points
under two minutes in a football game
only another one show me another one
that's it just show me another sack when
somebody's down 16 points and it's under
two minutes of the football game
do you
show me a pass attempt when somebody's
down 16 points and the clock is under
two minutes that's what you do you stray
and farve at the hall you guys talk
about this or no never been there well
all three of us have never been in the
same
spot again
come on
so you would have not you i wouldn't
even say would you bring it of course
you would
of course you'd bring it up wouldn't you
no i wouldn't no it'll ruin the moment
okay
i'll give me a selfie first
[Laughter]
i wouldn't bring it up i wouldn't bring
it up no no no no
10 years later or something like that i
don't remember but okay he did what he
did one because he called me and i i
should have called it then one i'm like
man relax
all right so last one for you the team
that does it's you're very confident
about the bucks repeating so the team
that concerns you the most i didn't say
anything about repeating good about my i
feel good about my team going to the
playoffs cause i got the one man that if
anybody can get it done he will
yes he will there's no doubt about that
so so the team that concerns you the
most is which then which one everyone
else in the tournament which one nowhere
come on
which one listen man you're telling me
this green bears is just vibing if you
need 17 in motion across the middle of
the field why the hell open you you
deserve to be beat
and then you get baker mayfield go up in
there and go throw full interceptions i
mean good god almighty man
baker mayfield had him
on the ropes and only thing he got to do
is make a a
seven route to in dooku or out route
didn't do cool but he can't throw either
one of them with that little jerk with
his back foot what is that anyway i've
never seen a quarterback turn his foot
like that to throw the ball what is that
about with baker are you telling me with
baker had him on the ropes that brady
stafford or any of these nfc teams
that's going to be in the the the
tournament can't go up there and get
them come on dawg green bay is not that
we watched them take the ball out of
aaron rodgers to mvp hands because they
had an analytics guy who's never won
yeah well that ain't happening again
that's not happening okay no i'm not
yeah well let's live this thing up and
let's see what happens because my
quarterback threw four interceptions
that day
and you still couldn't beat me and we
are we who fear green bay
not in tampa bay i know better than that
nah
happy new year 99 thanks for the call
man
you take care of it's always good to
talk to you all right back at you it's
warren
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here